where'd you grow up you said a rural
area it was yeah I mean it was rural at
the time it was a little town called
Lithia Springs Georgia which was only
about 18 miles from from downtown
Atlanta but but it you know it was it
completely it was a different world and
you you there was like hog-calling
contest when you were a kid that is
something that did not happen when I
grew up in Brookline Massachusetts
get caught like dairy cow no we didn't
do any of that stuff yeah yeah we did we
had that up-and-up in Dahlonega there
was a great little little town up in up
in North North Georgia and it was the
the Dahlonega kind of good the gold rush
days and it was a big like kind of
mountain kind of festival you know and
and it had basically kind of the redneck
Olympics they had hog-calling they had
like the greased pig and the greased
pole and and I won one of them I'm the
go I got won the gold medal winner of
the hog calling contest what is that
Georgia when you when you call them ah
no you just got it like I mean there's
no hogs here anyway but it was a hog at
home I mean it's just like and then you
have to throw in like a sooie sooie
you know or something like that
my wife is plump my wife is from LA and
I remember doing it for my wife the
first time if she said don't ever do
that again
yeah I can take a stereotypical person
from the South what are you and what is
that you said greased pig what happens
with the greased pig well you know I
mean how much what's the least I think
they put money around the pigs neck
right it's the least amount of money
that you can put on an animal and have
somebody do something to them or make
themselves look like a jerk like an
[ __ ] or something right and so they
would put like 10 bucks around the pigs
neck and then you just run around and
let they would lather it with grease or
whatever and you run around and try to
tackle it just it's awesome to get right
to get the 10 bucks to get the 10 bones
they're a strategy to that like I
honestly don't know if there's a
strategy to grabbing a group I think I
mean you'd have to like I think it's
something like you'd have to get him
like position you exactly I'd say that
Kama Sutra and then they would like they
would just do the pole you would think
they would do it with something else I
don't I don't know all right but I
didn't win neither one of those I didn't
even place right and the pig or the pole
then yes the just the Hong Kong and as
far as I'm concerned you're a loser
believe I'm talking to you
you